i've got an article here that was
forwarded to me by
one of my viewers a few weeks ago and as
always i'm slow to
go through them and you know make a
topic of it
i thought this would be a great piece
for my live show
you know i've also talked about it in my
book in the red flag chapter
under uh avoiding the unhappy and
unlucky which is what i've titled this
live stream
because it's essentially what you're
dealing with um there was a survey done
in 2020 march of 2020
uh which concluded that 56.3 percent of
white liberal women under the age of 30
have a mental health a diagnosed mental
health issue
so i thought i'd uh grab the article
kind of tear
through it and give you guys some of my
thoughts and feedback
i'll be taking some call-ins tonight so
if you have a question
or if you want to contribute to the
topic and experience maybe
i'll drop the link probably about 20
minutes or so
make sure you have headphones and a good
internet connection and we can chop it
up a little bit live
so um there is the
housekeeping item let me uh grab the
article again and throw it back up on
the screen
uh the link by the way is in the
description guys so if i ever
cite any article or any information on
one of my shows
it's always linked in the description
you just have to expand it down a bit
and you'll see it there
uh we got some of our uh good-looking
brothers
in the live chat got moth infamous
rifles here today oh welcome bro we got
a good life account there oh before i
continue let me just remove this real
quick
uh do me a solid guys if you're watching
this somewhere else on the
interwebs uh come over to youtube and
just uh watch over here just helps me
out with the algorithms
a bit and if you haven't smashed the
like button do that so that's the
youtube link that i'm dropping there
um back to the article all right
uh articles written by a lady
by the name of elizabeth condra
i always tell you guys to consider the
source this is your author right here
um from what i understand she's been
through the
liberal and conservative grinds so she's
well balanced
from what i understand the way she does
her writing i'm going to skip through
much of the introduction you guys can
read that all if you really want to
again the links below um
women and mental illness they talk about
postpartum depression
40 or women are 40 more likely to
develop depression than men
due to lower levels of serotonin um i
don't know if you guys know this but
it's said something like one in four
women are on
antidepressants or ssris
these are not good things they do all
kinds of weird things to the human body
including pack on weight and mess with
sexual desire and libido
so it's my view that you want to stay
away from anyone
or not invite anyone into your inner
circle
that's on medication like this not that
you can't you can do whatever you want
with your time trust me
a lot of people don't listen to what i
say and some people point and sputter
and get upset
but it's my view that if you want a easy
and fun life you want to avoid this so
that's what the unplugged alpha is all
about my book is a distilled version of
everything i've put out on my
channel if you haven't read it it's
available on amazon it's a great
day listen if you've got a long drive
it's less than five hours in audible
or you can tear through the book it's
about 200 pages
grab it on amazon um depression
biology okay let's go to the study so
here's what the study found
the study in question which by the way
isn't from a news source or media outlet
but pew research for heaven's sakes
is when all said and done pretty damning
interestingly enough the study which is
titled
pew american trends panel wave 64.
bizarre title for the study uh dated
march 2020
over a year ago yet it took a phd
candidate in a political science posting
about the study on twitter for it to
garner even a smidge of attention
interesting so here's a link to the
tweets
some of the charts that this guy
distilled i'll let you guys take a look
at that if you want
i'll stick to this article here a smidge
of attention the study which examined
white liberals moderates and
conservatives
both male and female found that
conservatives were far less likely to be
diagnosed with mental health issues
than those who identified as either
liberal or even very liberal
what's more white women suffered the
worst of all
suffered white women ages 18 to 29 who
identified as liberal were given a
mental health diagnosis from medical
professionals so again these are
diagnosed women
they're not uh actually i think in the
first chart over here
yeah the question that they asked them
was has a doctor you guys probably won't
be able to breathe this but has a doctor
or other health care provider
ever told you that you have a mental
health condition
and this is the percent that said yes
women
almost double the conservative
numbers on the liberal side but again
the question was has a doctor or other
healthcare provider ever told you that
you have a mental health show
these are the ones that have been
diagnosed now when i
posted the link to this live stream on
my twitter earlier
uh guys were chiming in and they were
like okay what about the other part that
aren't diagnosed so there's a portion
again it's 56.3 percent uh
right here that word that were diagnosed
by medical
health professionals what about the
other
you know 37 percent that aren't being
diagnosed
that might be walking around not dealing
with
these issues um mental health issues
okay uh liberal or even very what's more
white women suffer the worst of all
white women ages 18 to 29 who identified
as liberal were given a mental health
diagnosis for medical professionals at a
rate of 56.3 percent
compared to 28.4 and moderates and 27.3
in conservatives 56.3 is almost double
okay we're talking almost double that's
pretty crazy
i don't know about you guys i've dated a
lot of liberal women
identifying with liberal values i mean
here in canada you know voting for
liberal parties or socialist parties
like the new democrat party
um loving justin trudeau
loving you know universal basic income
free stuff free health care free free
free free a lot of that
now the study gets into why this is
so let's keep going down zac goldberg
the doctoral candidate in question this
is the guy that posted the tweet thread
that i opened up
here this guy zach goldberg
the doctoral candidate in question
consolidated the study info and a set of
visuals and posted them on a thread on
twitter you guys can check that out
but it's important to note that he
clarified the following i didn't write
this thread to mock white liberals or
their apparent disproportionate rates of
mental illness
you shouldn't either in quotations
rather it's
sorry this is a question that's
unexplored which may shed a light on
uh attitudinal differences towards a new
world attitudinal
differences towards various social
policies he's right
uh dr lal rossiter a board-certified
psychiatrist who's treated mental
disorders for over 30 years agrees
and adds that white liberalism thrives
on supposedly championing workers
minorities the little guy women and the
unemployed
who they continuously see as wrong
cheated
oppressed disenfranchised exploited and
victimized
with little or no agency of their own a
view that often mutates into the
infantilized infant infantilizing
and patronizing of certain groups within
a narrative
uh when these rays to think reality is a
subject bump
okay that's a quote from the article uh
the people responsible for the crime so
it goes on to talk about who's
whose fault this is so roster who's
rossiter that was the
board certified psychiatrist okay roster
tells it
poverty disease war ignorance
unemployment racial prejudice
ethnic and gender discrimination modern
technology capitalism globalism and
imperialism
then it ends there doesn't talk about
any of the other isms like marxism
or feminism it's always the other ones
right
in the radical liberal mind this
suffering is inflicted on the innocent
by various predators
and persecutors big business big
corporations
greedy capitalists now i don't know if
you guys noticed last month
was it june was gay pride month or
something or lg qbtq plus seven
whatever all those acronyms are you
notice how all the big corporations are
pandering to that a lot lately
they're trying to clean up their image
that's what i'm
looking at anyway so they're pointing
and sputtering rossiter says
the white liberals are pointing and
sputtering at big business big
corporation greedy capitalist and us
imperialist are the oppressors the rich
the wealthy
the powerful and the selfish
that's pretty much an exhaustive list of
every grievance and every perpetrator
that progressives see as responsible for
these injustices
which plague our disenfranchised
communities while moderates and
conservatives
seemingly sit idly by unconcerned with
anything but their own privilege
but as the study exemplifies the
champions of these causes
white women in particular aren't exactly
living the liberated utopia they believe
we should all be in living
uh taking it seriously and closing
it's truly unfortunate that so many
women are facing these kinds of issues
and that
this uh prevalence of mental illness
among progressive women might be
being weaponized for political purposes
gee do you think so
if there's one thing this topic you know
what all of this would get
cleared up and go away very very quickly
policies
would improve very very quickly in
western countries if those diagnosed
with mental disorders were not able to
vote
oh my god rich did you just say that i
can't believe you just said that
yeah i said that hey sorry not sorry
but let's be honest i mean if you have a
mental disorder why should you be voting
on
policies that govern a country right
anyway
if there's one thing this topic deserves
it's uh delicacy and empathy which i
don't have a lot of
but you guys don't watch me for delicacy
and empathy you guys
you guys come here for the cold hard
truth that's what i deliver right
we should feel compassion for these
women especially if we've struggled with
mental health ourselves
but at the heart of the matter is this
progressivism
is an ideology that supposedly demands
equality for all
yeah equality of outcome is really what
it talks about
and one that keeps score at an to an
exhaustive degree yeah
you'll notice that these liberal uh what
these
these strongly liberal women very far
left-leaning like to keep score a lot
i've noticed that anyway personally in
my dating life
the privilege between social classes
between races between men and women
between religious and non-religious and
more all have to be constantly monitored
and inequality has to be exposed for the
purposes of accountability
that kind of behavior isn't just
unrealistic it's unstable
in all honesty it's understandable that
anxiety and depression thrive on these
kinds of environments when we're
focusing on it every minute
problematic issue in our world and not
able to take comprehensive productive
action
to solve these problems i wonder how
much of this
is manufactured and intentionally
put out there by
these uh strong left-leaning liberalists
i mean it raises the question right you
know to
create an uns unstable environment and
some of these mental this
i mean it's almost like they're abusing
these people
you know they're using them for their
own collective you know thoughts and
needs we're getting the closing thoughts
here so we're almost wrapping up
uh there's also the unrelenting focus on
oppression verbal violence
microaggressions we know that building
resiliency against hardship
is the best weapon against depression
anxiety so why don't we focus on that
why do we have to sit around and say oh
poor or you
we're very sorry about how you're
feeling right now when we're going to
put a safe space here for you how about
just
resiliency and hardship right that's
what
that's what i was made of when i was a
kid you know resiliency and hardship you
know
made kids stronger you know turn them
into strong
adult men you know the boys anyway
you